"
AMONGST OUR GUESTS, MARK LEVIN.
HE'S FIRED UP AND YOU WILL WANT
TO HEAR WHAT HE HAS TO SAY.
THINGS HAVE CHANGED IN THIS
ELECTION SEASON.
THE REPUBLICAN'S DREAMS OF
TAKING BACK THE SENATE
ORIGINALLY FOCUSED ON ONE SEAT.
BUT NOW THEY HAVE TO HOLD A
SEAT.
PAT TOOMEY'S SEAT.
MEHMET OZ FINDS HIMSELF DOWN
DOUBLE DIGITS TO JOHN FETTERMAN.
BUT LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR
FETTERMAN SUFFERED A STROKE.
HE HAD TO TAKE WEEKS OFF THE
TRAIL.
BUT THE LEAD WAS SO BIG THEY
THOUGHT THEY COULD RIDE IT OUT,
STAY IN THE BASEMENT AND RIDE IT
OUT.
BUT OZ CONTINUED TO CAMPAIGN.
>> TELLING YOU THAT YOU ARE NOT
FIT TO BE SERVE.
SEND US BACK TO NEW JERSEY.
SEND ME TO DV.
>> I ALWAYS THOUGHT IT WAS
PRETTY EMPATHETIC.
EMPHATIC.
I AM SORRY, EMPATHETIC.
BRIAN: THE GUY IS WEAK ON CRIME
AND ADMITS IT.
>> I'M EFFECTIVE ON CRIME.
AND I BELIEVE IN SECOND CHANCES.
AND I HAVE ONE ON THAT RECORD.
BRIAN: MURDER ONE AND YOU MURDER
TWO IS THAT A TIME FOR SECOND
CHANCES.
HE'S ALSO AGAINST THE LIFE BLOOD
OF THE STATE, FRACKING.
>> THE PRESIDENT'S TEAM USED
FRACKING AS A WEDGE ISSUE.
NO ONE CARES ABOUT IT WITH THE
PANDEMIC GOING.
I AM NOT PRO FRACKING.
I SIGNED THE NO FOSSIL FUEL
PLEDGE BEFORE THE COOL KIDS WERE
DOING IT IN 2015.
BRIAN: AS USUAL ON THE LEFT YOU
ARE NOT TO BELIEVE YOUR EYES OR
EARS.
FETTERMAN IS FINE, HIS BELIEFS
ARE MAINSTREAM.
BUT THE PROBLEM IS HE'S NOT FINE
AND HE'S NOT IN THE CENTER.
BUT DON'T YOU DARE POINT THAT
OUT EVEN IF YOU ARE FROM A
FRIENDLY NETWORK.
>> WALK ME THROUGH WHY WE NEED
THE CLOSED CAPTIONING AND HEWITT
WORKS.
>> SOMETIMES I WILL HEAR THINGS
IN A WAY THAT'S NOT PERFECTLY
CLEAR.
SO I USE CAPTIONING.
I'M ABLE TO SEE WHAT YOU ARE
SAYING IN CAPTIONING.
>> WE DID FIND IN SMALLTALK
BEFORE THE INTERVIEW WITHOUT
CAPTIONING, IT SEEMED IT WAS
DIFFICULT FOR FETTERMAN TO
UNDERSTAND OUR CONVERSATION.
BRIAN: WHAT IS WRONG WITH THAT
REPORT.
THEY DECIDE TO ATTACK THE
REPORTER.
>> LOTS OF OTHER JOURNALISTS WHO
HAVE INTERVIEWED FETTERMAN
UNLEASHED ON HER.
>> I THOUGHT IT WAS
INAPPROPRIATE WHEN SHE SAID
SMALLTALK.
>> MAYBE IT'S HER.
>> OTHER JOURNALISTS WHO DEALT
WITH FETTERMAN CAME FORWARD AND
SAID THEY HAD A DIFFERENT
EXPERIENCE.
BRIAN: BLUE CHECK LIBERALS ON
TWITTER WASTED NO TIME OF
SLAMMING THE REPORTER FOR HER
ACCURATE ACCOUNT OF WHAT SHE
EXPERIENCED.
ONE JOURNALIST SAID I TALKED TO
JOHN FETTERMAN FOR OVER AN HOUR.
MAYBE THIS REPORTER IS BAD AS
SMALL TALK.
THE BIDEN BASEMENT PLAN, AND NOW